Democrats like to say they truly care
about illegal immigrants as human beings
but once in a while they slip up and
reveal their true reasons for wanting
open borders take a look
tourism construction
agriculture I mean you're going to have
vegetables rotting in the fields you're
going to have construction sites that
will lie dormant or certainly will
struggle to get Workers to be able to uh
to to help make sure that they can make
progress those folk who are coming
across are the ones who are
helping to
put food on our table without them we're
not able to eat immigrants pick the food
we eat clean our homes and look after
the most precious in our families we
have a shortage of workers in our
country and you see even in Florida some
of the farmers and The Growers saying
why are you shipping these
immigrants up north we need them to pick
the crops down here
all right here now with reaction 2024
Republican presidential candidate vivec
Rama Swami is back with us sir how are
you
hey good how are you
all right we had the border under
control I'm afraid about the drugs I'm
afraid about the human trafficking I'm
afraid about the cost we cannot afford
to feed house educate offer health care
and assistance to everybody uh that is
entering this country but also what
about those people on the terror watch
list that we caught but what about the
people we didn't catch they're building
Terror cells right here in this country
and that means they're plotting planning
and scheming and attack to destroy and
murder Americans do you agree with that
I fully agree with that Sean and if you
also look you were just talking about
the fentanyl crossing the southern
border that is also killing over 200
Americans per day on American soil and
so that's why I think we need to take
this to the next level building the wall
alone is not sufficient this is killing
Americans on American soil that is a
justification for using the U.S military
to actually secure our Southern border
that's why I was the first candidate to
say it if we can use our military to
secure somebody else's border somewhere
else we can certainly use our own
military to secure our own Southern
border and we need leadership to
actually deliver on that this is what do
you think the motivation is why why have
they adopted a policy that they're going
to leave the borders wide open and then
lie to us and say that the board is
secure which if I hear one more time I
hate being lied to but between mayorcus
and Biden they lie constantly
well it's like the Democratic party of
2023 Sean I really mean this sounds a
lot like the Democratic party of 1863.
just listen to some of those clips you
played using short-term economic
justifications to justify illegal and
immoral Behavior the vegetables will rot
in the field we need people to pluck our
crops this is the thing that Democrats
were saying in the south in the 1860s to
justify a different form of immoral and
illegal behavior in the form of slavery
now they're using that justification for
illegal immigrants to be able to turn
the other way and abandon the rule of
law Sean I will refuse to stand by and
watch this idly I'm actually going to
the south side of Chicago on Friday not
a popular stop for many Republicans on a
campaign Trail but America First
includes all Americans and even though
that is a black community that mostly
votes Democrat on the south side of
Chicago they too are being plagued by
this same Trend where high schools are
being taken over and turned into
encampments for illegals crossing the
southern border and there every bit as
angry about it as the people in New York
and so I think this is a unifying
American issue to say we stand for the
rule of law in this country whether it's
the Durham report whether it's Neely
whether it's the Southern Cross whether
it's the crossings in the southern
border the deeper cancer is that we've
abandoned the rule of law and if I'm
elected president Sean I'll tell you
this we are going to restore it once and
for all in this country all right
Swami thank you my friend hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else